T'S SO GREAT TO HAVE
YOU HERE AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THE REST OF THE CAST COULDN'T BE
HERE BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
MEMBERS OF THE STATE AND IT
WAS SUCH A GREAT ENSEMBLE CAST.
>> THANK YOU, CHRIS.
PEOPLE ASK US ALL THE TIME,
IS THE STATE GOING TO GET BACK
TOGETHER?
IT'S HARD TO GET US TOGETHER
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT FRANKLY WE DON'T SEE EACH
OTHER AS OFTEN AS WE'D LIKE TO.
>> BUT LET'S FACE IT, AT LEAST
JOE LO TRUGLIO ISN'T HERE.
NOBODY'S MISSING HIM!
(LAUGHS)
>> GUYS!
GUYS, I'M HERE!
IT'S ME!
>> Chris: HEY, IT'S JOE LO
TRUGLIO!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
YOU ALL LOOK TERRIFIC.
YOU LOOK GREAT.
I DRESS LIKE THIS NOW
SINCE THE GLOBES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO DON'T KNOW, JOE IS ON A SHOW
THAT NOBODY WATCHES CALLED
"BROOKLYN NINE-NINE."
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S SO FUNNY,
IT'S SO GREAT TO SEE YOU GUYS.
I RARELY SEE ANY OF THE OTHER
GUYS, LIKE THAT GUY GLEN GARANT.
>> BEN GARANT?
>> I STOOD RIGHT IN LINE
IN FRONT OF HIM FOR 45 MINUTES.
"HEY, JOE!"
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
DID THE GLOBES CHANGE YOU?
AND NOT IN A GOOD WAY?
(LAUGHTER)
YEAH, I WORK HERE NOW.
I'M HERE EVERY DAY.
>> OH, YOU DO CRAFT SERVICE?
>> I BROUGHT YOU YOUR COFFEE,
YEAH, THAT WAS ME.
>> IT NEEDED MORE CREAM.
(LAUGHTER)
>> TOM IS HERE, TOO, BUT I
HAVEN'T SEEN HIM IN YEARS.
>> OH, I HEARD HE PASSED.
>> I THINK THAT MIGHT BE TRUE.
>> HE DID PASS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
TOM LENNON?
TOM LENNON WAS SUCH A GOOD
BEATLE.
>> HE WAS ONE OF THE BEST
BEATLES.
>> HE WROTE SO MANY GOOD SONGS.
>> GUYS, I PRETEND TO LOSE
THIS SHOW TWO NIGHTS A WEEK.
>> PRETEND, REALLY PRETEND
OR LOSING FOR REALS?
>> YOU'LL NEVER KNOW!
>> I'M SO GLAD YOU'RE NOT DEAD.
>> YOU GUYS, I WOULD LOVE
TO GET THE STATE TOGETHER.
I'M A HUGE FAN OF A COUPLE OF
YOU GUYS.
(LAUGHTER)
AND I WOULD LOVE...
I MEAN, WE'LL NEVER GET
SOME PEOPLE, LIKE WE'D NEVER
GET DAVID WAIN, FOR EXAMPLE.
>> HE'S BUSY.
HE'S GOT ALL THE INDEPENDENT
SPIRIT AWARDS, DIRECTING STUFF
AND...
>> I'M RIGHT HERE, YOU GUYS.
RIGHT HERE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I'M SUBBING FOR MY FRIEND BRUCE
ON CAMERA TWO TODAY, SO...
(LAUGHTER)
I'M ALSO DIRECTING THE SHOW.
OKAY, LET'S GET ANOTHER SHOT
OF THE THREE PANELISTS,
READY CAMERA ONE AND GO.
(LAUGHTER)
>> YOU KNOW WHO I REMEMBER FROM
THE STATE?
>> WHO WAS THAT?
>> HE USED TO DIRECT A LOT OF
THE STUFF, HE LOOKED LIKE A
PEDOPHILE...
(LAUGHING)
>> SHORT GUY?
>> NO, TALLER GUY.
>> GAY GUY?
>> NO.
>> BLACK GUY?
>> THERE WAS NEVER A BLACK GUY.
MICHAEL JANN.
>> OH, GOD.
>> WE'LL NEVER SEE THAT GUY
AGAIN.
>> (CLEARING THROAT)
HEY!
I HAVEN'T SEEN YOU GUYS IN LIKE
THREE TO FIVE YEARS.
(LAUGHTER)
AND I'M NOT INTO GAY
OR PEDOPHILIA ANYMORE.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE GUY WHO'D BE REALLY HARD
TO GET IS KEN MARINO.
I HAVEN'T SEEN HIM SINCE
I STOPPED GOING TO MEETINGS.
>> I WANT TO DIP MY BALLS IN IT!
>> Chris: KEN MARINO!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THANKS FOR BRINGING YOUR BALLS,
KEN MARINO!
THANKS FOR LETTING ME TAKE YOUR
BALLS.
ANOTHER HUGE HAND FOR THE
STATE!